here in this video we shall showcase
all 10 of the sea monsters of the
monsterverse including the subtitans and
the titans
we shall take entries from every media
that the most verse has in its belly
that means the comics novelization
movies and all we will also try to
arrange in size
so let's get to it mark yeager mark
[ __ ] is an underwater scaly reptilian
thailand about the size of a whale like
other marine animals she has a flat face
with the nostrils above her human-like
eyes
and her head protrudes backwards
covering her neck
mariega's skeleton is visible in her
death and a jagged rift stretches from
her neck
to her abdomen due to the fact that
godzilla killed her
this titan has a small mouth with very
sharp teeth and the scales resemble that
of godzilla it doesn't seem to have
visible limbs
mark yeager would have been more than a
hundred feet long
number two the maya squid this creature
is not a titan but because of its huge
size in relation to other animals
it can be classified as a sub-titan
along with the skull crawlers and the
genital swarm
it is a sea creature that also inhabits
the waterways of skull island
which is connected to the oceans this
creature is over 100 feet long and looks
like a mix between a squid and an
octopus
the maesquits are ambush predators that
lurk in the waterways of skull island
for unsuspecting prey
being massive prehistoric cephalopods
they don't seem to have much of a
personality
number three the janitor this creature
is a sub-tyrant and was seen in the
comics godzilla dominion
janitor looks like a donkliostius an
extinct prehistoric fish
it has a blue body with red fins and
also two arms that end in claws
its jaws have large inner body plates
that protrude outwards like teeth
through a hive mine it was able to
monitor smaller members of its species
creating a large swarm it was quick
enough to surprise godzilla before he
even realized it was
there and it was able to bite through
the scales of the g-man and draw first
blood
the subtitle is around 150 to 200 feet
long
number four the leviathan this titan the
leviathan was found in loch ness
scotland by monarch and outpost 49 was
built around it
leviathan can travel in and out of loch
ness by the use of the hollow earth
tunnels
it is believed by many loch ness monster
terrorists that there are tunnels on the
loch ness connecting to the sea
it's designed somewhat obscure as it
kinda has
five to six limbs growing outwards like
a starfish but at the same time
it has these skins attached to these
limbs kind of like the feet of a frog
anyway its design was seen in the x-ray
photos in the monitor screens during
kotm
number 5 cilla this titan stands 341
feet tall and although it was awakened
from a desert it is a primarily aquatic
or oceanic island
sila is a giant armored cephalopod with
brown coloration
and six very long bony lightly haired
legs each with two joints and
ending with a claw with small spikes
growing out of the first
joints she also has a plated mantel with
10 tendrils and a pair of orange eyes
in dominici is seen attacking human
ships until godzilla fends her off and
kicks her and forces her to flee to an
island near the tip of south america
before hibernating in its freezing lake
number six amhulu
yet another thailand that can survive
both in land and water amhulu first
appears battling behemoth and breaks one
of his
opponent's dust amhunuk's unique
muscular structure allows him to control
plants and
extend his arms many times their
original length
so his size is indeterminate although he
would be around
behemoth's height he is a huge demonic
looking mammalian thailand and looks
like a tree in design his full limbs are
made of loose
wine-like flesh capable of stretching to
tremendous lengths ending in massive
four-digit claws
number seven titanos nakika nakika has
the appearance of a giant octopus or a
squid with a thick curving shell that
covers its massive brain and green blood
nakika is revealed to have at least
eight
thick tentacles resembling several rows
of suckers in godzilla dominion
as well as bright blue eyes and an
insecticide phase
an internal shell and vibrant iridescent
skin
nakika's brain is much larger than
necessary to control
his body giving it incredible
intelligence surpassing most tyrants
titanos nakika uses its tentacles for
combat which are strong and capable of
dragging
down and even an entire marine monarch
outpost
this island would have been around 300
to 400 feet long
number 8 godzilla well we all know the
king of the monsters is also the emperor
of the oceans
he's like a monster battleship that can
never be sunk
godzilla is a primarily aquatic titan
and he spends most of his days swimming
around the world and also has underwater
resting places
although his origins as well as the
other titans are from the hollow earth
he has adapted to live in the world's
oceans and he has
visible guilds and can stay submerged
indefinitely
he might also be the longest underwater
titan around 850 feet long
although his height is 400 feet he might
have been the longest if not for this
next titan number nine tiamat this titan
can lift both on land and underwater
monarch discovered tiamat in stone
mountain georgia and established outpost
53 around her
tiamat appears as a rival thailand who
battles godzilla
after seizing one of the latter's old
layers godzilla then defeats tiamat and
sends her into dormancy after a brief
but intense fight
tiamat greatly resembles a giant
serpentine leafy
sea dragon with crocodile-like jaws
barbells and yellow eyes
her scales are purple while her fins are
blue in color
and it can manipulate water to create
maelstroms and also
it is the longest around 1 000 feet long
by our estimates
and number 10 the beetle and death
titans in godzilla dominion in the
artwork showing godzilla searching for
his old lair and to rest and recuperate
after restoring the natural order
it is worth noting that there were lots
of dead islands and subtitles that lay
scattered in the seafloor near his lair
some of those resemble cephalopods and
squids maybe they were
maya squids and krakens while another
was seen
to be like a crab or a beetle they were
all dead and the remains seemed to lack
decomposition
and stayed the same after death and so
with that we come to the end of this
video on the 10 plus c
monsters of the most verse arrange in
ascending order
well kind of subscribe and hit that bell
button
till next one take care fam